hey guys it's max we just got in
samsung's brand new s21
ultra and today we'll be comparing it to
apple's iphone 12 pro max and seeing
which one of these
is the flagship king in this video i'm
not only going to cover things like
specs
design and performance but i want to
know how good
is the brand new snapdragon chip with
that new x60 modem so we're gonna do a
speed test
and also the new display with higher
brightness
high resolution and high refresh rate
and i want to test out the new
fingerprint sensor this must be much
faster the first thing that i want to
mention is how
tiny this box is and that is because
samsung
after making fun of apple went ahead and
got rid of the charge room but i think
that's more of a headline grabbing thing
because they gave me
all of this stuff for free including one
of these 45 watt chargers
when i pre-ordered this samsung s21
ultra so
it's kind of funny to me let's go ahead
and open it up and it'll be my first
experience
with this brand new phone all right this
thing looks pretty dang massive it's
always interesting how a small
difference in screen size
makes a big difference and i did get the
silver one
let's go ahead and peel off all of these
stickers so we can get a better look
and man what do you guys think about
that camera bump
let me know down in the comments do you
like it do you hate it
is it interesting for you it does make
the bezel over here the frame
really really thick holding this thing
in my hand the first thing that really
pops out is how heavy it is
it definitely feels chunky but with that
said picking up the iphone 12 pro max
it also feels very heavy does feel maybe
slightly lighter or maybe it's just the
fact that the sides are square
i'll have angelica put up both weights
right over there
the other thing that stands out are all
of these fingerprints
i figured that this silver model
wouldn't get as much fingerprints as
that matte black one
but take a look at that the iphone has
barely any fingerprints and i haven't
even wiped it down i've been using it
as my daily driver whereas this samsung
after just a little bit
look how much fingerprints there are as
far as comfort in the hands
the round edges do feel a little bit
softer or something like that
but these flat edges on the iphone 12
pro max
they definitely give you a lot more grip
it feels like this phone's not going to
go anywhere now the s21 is definitely
quite a bit
thicker you could definitely tell right
there but that is only the beginning
if we go ahead and spin these and we
compare the camera bumps
that is an insane difference the
thickness there
is crazy now does that mean that the s21
ultra's cameras are going to be much
better than the iphones
well we are going to find out in our
blind camera comparison that we have
coming up these are always so much fun
and not only we're going to do one
against the iphone but i'm also going to
toss
in the note 20 ultra and the s20
ultra in one of those and we will see
truly
how much better the cameras have gotten
if you guys want to see that click that
subscribe button
actually it's right there below enable
notifications and with that you can help
us reach our goal
of 600 000 subs before march which is
our two year mark if you do that
that would be amazing and i have to say
that overall as far as the design
the iphone 12 max is definitely much
more premium
feeling and looking compared to the s21
ultra it almost seems like they took a
step back
and now it's time to set up my
fingerprint and test out how this new
sensor works
let's go ahead and get this set up all
right let's see how fast this thing is
all right pretty quick there there's
still a little bit of a delay
and honestly it doesn't seem that much
faster than the note 20 ultra about the
same
but we will be doing a side-by-side
comparison against that showing you guys
which one you should buy so we'll find
out but now let's go ahead and do a
little test
against the iphone let's turn off the
screen okay tap
and go up it's hard to do with both but
i feel like i'm getting a little better
at it
alright well let's try one by one you
guys saw the speed here
just a little this way and with the
iphone
tap and scroll tap and swipe so the s21
definitely seems faster and of course
with everything going on it is great to
be able to have a fingerprint
sensor now i am super excited to compare
these displays and see how much
better the new s21 is but first
i want to check out the differences in
speakers samsung has been doing an
amazing job
upgrading the speakers they sound great
they're loud so let's go ahead and take
a listen
guys put on a pair of headphones and
let's see which one
sounds better
[Music]
all right guys go ahead and comment down
below which one sounded better to you
now to my ears the samsung definitely
takes the win this has been a common
trend
it's a little bit louder not only is it
louder overall the mids are also louder
whereas on the iphone it's usually the
high frequencies with these newer models
that really stand out so samsung great
job and now let's go ahead and compare
the displays now the first thing that
stands out to me
is just how blue the screen of the s21
ultra is out of the box it looks crazy
the iphone is a little bit
warmer but i did find a setting over
here where you can actually
limit the blue eye comfort shield and
then it does make it look
much closer to the iphone a little bit
more natural now along with that
out of the box our screen resolution is
set to
full hd plus it is not set to the
highest option so i'm going to go ahead
and change it
and thankfully with the s21 ultra we can
actually keep it in adaptive motion
smoothness so
up to 120 hertz and have that high
resolution
setting so right now we have much more
pixels than the iphone
and we have twice the refresh rate so as
you can see in our super slow motion
footage
the screen is much smoother on the s21
and this is what really makes your phone
feel snappy now as far as display
sharpness i cannot see a difference both
look fantastic
but we will be testing out hdr video
really soon
so we'll see if we can see a difference
there now with that said when we used to
have to turn down the resolution on the
samsung phones in order to get 120 hertz
there i could definitely see a massive
difference so now there is
no disadvantage on the s21 and now let's
compare the display brightness i
adjusted the top camera so we're not
blowing out the screen and the iphone is
insanely bright
but the samsung has the newest best oled
display
so let's go ahead and max out the
brightness and see how they compare
and as you guys could tell the samsung
is not as bright
if you want to manually adjust it that's
because samsung puts a limit on there
where apple doesn't now if you're using
auto brightness and you take these
outside into the sun they're going to be
about the same as far as brightness
now i went ahead and i turned down the
brightness on the iphone to match
so we can look at the color or
brightness shift
and taking a look at these phones the
color doesn't really change on the
iphone they did a great job this year
but the samsung shifts quite a bit here
you go you guys can see from that side
camera
how it looks and then here's the
sideways shot
the samsung got much more blue and now
let's compare hdr
video playback both the quality and just
how good that hdr
is the iphone is playing back this hdr
video clip at
4k which is crazy but the samsung it
looks like it's still
only letting us play back at 1080p in
hdr
taking a look at the differences wow
this is
massive and i was not expecting this
both of these are turned up to the max
hdr is working but the iphone is so much
brighter
not only that but just the bright spots
are popping a lot more where the samsung
it just looks all gray and dull almost
like hdr
isn't working and not only that the
detail
in the iphone from that over sampled 4k
image
just looks stunning compared to the
1080p that's playing
on samsung's super high resolution
display so as far as hdr video the
iphone is the clear winner but who knows
maybe samsung will fix this issue with a
firmware update
if they do we'll let you guys know in
our full review
of the s21 ultra and now let's go ahead
and compare the 5g
speeds i'm gonna go ahead and pop my sim
in here both these phones are connected
to t-mobile and we don't have the ultra
fast
millimeter wave 5g that is
pretty much non-existent and you have to
be right next to the tower but we do
have 5g
that is quite a bit faster than 4g so
let's see how these stack up
all right we are connected and what's
interesting is that the iphone is only
showing
two bars out of four as you guys can see
right there whereas
the s21 ultra is showing five bars so
let's go ahead and run it
they're both connected to the same tower
to the same server
wow okay this is weird the iphone has
only two bars but we're getting
incredible speed speeds that we've been
getting
uh the last few months we've actually
been uploading a lot of videos
through our phone because of how fast it
is but the s21
is falling behind we have pretty much 55
compared to 12 and a half as far as
download and then the upload speed
is much closer at 19 compared to 17. now
the real test is going to be
when i take this s21 ultra to a few
spots in town
where there is very little service to no
service
i'll see how it does and i will report
back to you guys in the full review
but for now the iphone wins that one and
now let's compare
the rest of the performance we have
geekbench 5 opened up right here we're
going to run our cpu test
we have the brand new snapdragon 888
processor it's 5
nanometers now and let's go ahead and
run our cpu
test another difference that we have is
that we have 12 gigs of ram here
on the s21 ultra compared to just six
gigs
we have a result and this is incredible
i was not expecting this big of a
difference honestly the s21
it seems like it actually caught up to
the a13
which was not a five nanometer chip
whereas apple's
a14 is absolutely smoking it
uh we have about 24 higher performance
in multi-core
and 41 higher performance in
single core i thought it was going to be
closer
but that is very interesting i guess so
specs alone
don't mean much now of course we also
have differences in graphics
so let's go ahead and we're going to
close this down i have gfx bench opened
up we're going to do the same exact
high tier test let's go ahead and hit
start all right we
are complete and it looks like we got 27
frames per second
on the s21 and 38.6 per frames per
second
on the iphone so that is a difference of
43
once again i'm kind of surprised or
maybe shocked i expected the graphics to
actually be
closer than the cpu whereas this is
actually the biggest difference in cpu
performance that we've seen
but with that said vadim is actually
going to be doing a gaming test
and we'll see how these compare in real
world gaming of course the samsung has
many advantages such as maybe better
cooling so the screen might not dim
might not get as hot
has a bigger battery and it has that 120
hertz display
so make sure you guys enable those
notifications if you guys want to see
that now even though the processor and
graphics are slower in the s21
this phone has a massive advantage and
that is battery life
that chip has a new x60 modem for 5g
that sips power compared to the iphone
and not only that
we have a 5 000 milliamp hour battery
installed
compared to about 36 3700 on the iphone
and along with that not only do you get
to enjoy the 120 hertz screen
it also will go down all the way to 10
frames per second if it needs to like
when it's sitting here
and that also saves battery so even if
you select
the best quality 120 hertz you're still
gonna get a few hours of extra battery
life
with the s21 now here's an estimate
compared to
uh what i know so far with my usage but
i will get back
once we get a full test now another very
cool thing
about the s21 is that you can use an s
pen with it for the very first time now
unfortunately
the s pens are sold out it's going to
take a couple more weeks to get
but let's see if the one from the note
20 will work all right
and bam right away we have our nice
little pop-up for notes and you get all
these
little shortcuts to what you can do and
as i'm hovering even from a pretty far
distance
our little pointer is showing up and
let's see
i'm opening stuff up here no issues so
yes if you have an
older um samsung phone and you have an s
pen or you just go online and buy one of
these maybe
for much cheaper than the new ones it
will work now of course there's nowhere
to store it
there's no cutouts samsung would rather
have a bigger battery which is good
but i think that is a good option
instead of taking up extra space
and now let's talk about the cameras and
i have to say
this is just getting ridiculous so look
at these cutouts
on the samsung it basically seems like
the more circles you have the better the
iphone looks classy
you have three cameras on the back and
then we have the lidar sensor
but here we have a laser sensor that
looks like a camera
we have the telescopic sensor there's a
lot going on
let's go ahead and flip these over i
have the camera app opened
and it looks like samsung is still
adding
little filters on here now let's go to
face
i don't want any of this smoothing i
hate that they do that out of the box
all right we got rid of that and that
actually looks pretty
dang good now what i'm excited to check
out
is not that selfie camera it is our
crazy zoom so this year
the zoom over here is not a four times
optical in the rest digital it is
actually a 10 times
optical zoom let's go ahead and press
this
bam do you guys see that so there's our
light controller over there
everything looks really nice and sharp
and let's see how our iphone compares
with the iphone now we have a two and a
half times zoom
and we can go to 12 here let me kind of
match it up
all right we're about there and
wow actually did you guys see that
change it was blurry at first and it
looks like deep fusion kicked in
to fight against that true optical zoom
now in order for us to accurately test
out these cameras
i can't just take a couple snapshots
here we have to do
that blind camera comparison we're gonna
test out all the cameras
in a variety of lighting and low light
and then
without knowing which one is which we
will choose our favorites and mention
which are better and why those are so
awesome so we're gonna save our detailed
camera comparison
for that video and now let's talk about
value last year the s20 ultra was 1400
it was absolutely insane and thankfully
samsung went ahead and dropped the price
it is now 1200
but that also means it's still a hundred
dollars more than the iphone 12 pro max
and both have the same 128 gigs of
storage
and as you guys may have seen with that
sim tray you could no longer add your
own memory card to the samsung
so you have to buy it from them now
thankfully for only 50 bucks more
you can actually bump up to 256
gigabytes
where apple charges you another 100 and
you don't only get the extra storage you
also bump up to
16 gigs of ram which i don't really
think that you need
but it is still awesome to have more ram
in your phone than a lot of people have
on their laptops
and overall in terms of value i have to
say that the s21
ultra is coming out ahead yes it's a
little bit more expensive
but you get insane battery life with
that huge battery
and you get this amazing screen that
runs at 120 hertz at full resolution
and can go down to 10 hertz if it needs
to which is what we want from the iphone
now yes the processor
isn't as powerful but it still is plenty
fast
and we get all of these cameras with the
optical zoom
that i'm so excited to test out but you
guys let me know
your thoughts down in the comments
section below
now my biggest question is how does it
compare to the note 20 ultra
because this phone in my opinion is a
much nicer design it looks
so good it looks premium it feels
premium
and you can get it at a better price now
which will link
in the video description below so we are
going to be comparing this tomorrow head
to head
you guys can check that out thank you
guys for watching click that circle
above to help us
reach our goal of 600k subs before march
our two year mark that would be amazing
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video